[Müzik]
[Alkış]
hayat tek Hayat Biricik O yüzden Herkes
sevdiği işi yapmalı ya Yaptığın işi
Seveceksin Ya sevdiğin işi yapacaksın
sevdiğin işi yaparsan ömür boyu
çalışmazsın demiş Konfüçyüs Çok doğru Bu
bir altın orandır Çünkü Sevmediğin bir
işten kazandığın kazançla yaşadın
hayatta sevdiğin şeyleri yapmaya
çalışmak haydi yorucudur
Ben işime aşıktım her zaman ama gün
geldi üretemediğimi hissettiğim anlarda
oldu ve bu duygu da Boğuldum Evet zaman
zaman yaşadım Bunu tam düşmüşken
kırılganken küskünken yine yine ve
yeniden kendi içimde buldum düştüğüm
yerden kalkacak gücü Çünkü temelinde
Emek var Sebahat etmek var Cesaret
feragat ve çokça mücadele var yaptığımız
için meslek hayatımın çok büyük bir
bölümünü askere ve polisi adamış biri
olarak belki yüzlerce fotoğraf
çekilmişimdir çatışma bölgelerinde ve ne
acı ki bazen bana tek bir fotoğraf
karesi ve altına tüm yaşanmışlıkları
birkaç satıra sığdırma çabası kaldı evet
bu acılar kahrediyor azalmıyor cep
telefonum umutla başlayan ama
hazırlıksız bir sonla biten onlarca
mesajla dolu hepimiz duygu ve gururla
izledik yaptığınız haberi milli maç
heyecanıyla seyrettik diye yazmıştı
Aydoğan Aydın Paşa Peki nasıl başlamıştı
yıl 2017 bir telefon geldi haber
merkezine
şöyle diyordu telefonun ucundaki ses
terörle mücadele tarihinin en büyük
operasyonunu yapıyoruz Kato Dağı'nın
zirvesinde Gelip bizi haber yapar
mısınız dedi haber merkezine bu tür
teklifler zaman zaman gelir ama ben
asker ve polis sevdalıseri olarak Mümkün
Mertebe hiçbirini kırmamaya hepsine
gitmeye çalışırım elbette dedim Tabii
vakit var Bir yandan da operasyon devam
ediyor acele ediyorum uzatmayayım birkaç
gün içerisinde kendimi Mardin uçağında
buldum ardından karayoluyla Şırnak'a
gittim işte Tam da orada Şırnak 23 tümen
komutanlığının kapısında tanıştım o
güzel insanlarla İçeriye girdik
çaylarımızı içtik etraflıca bana
operasyonla anlattılar o güne kadar
nasıl yol aldıklarını neler yaptıklarını
ve ardından Bu arada Koskoca askeriyenin
içerisinde iki kadınız biri ben diğeri
Türkiye'nin ilk kadın İlke Jandarma
Komutanı Songül Yakut Yarbay
güzel yüzlü iri gözlü benden bir yaş
büyük artık lavaboya gideceğiz sonra
tuşlar bir an olsun Beni yalnız
bırakmıyor geldi yanıma dedim ki Evli
misiniz çocuğunuz var mı Ben mesleğimle
evliyim dedi ardından helikopter
rahatladık ve katodanın zirvesine çıktık
açıkçası kafamda sıradan bir operasyona
geliyoruz diye düşünmüşken gördüğüm
manzara inanılmazdı
terörle mücadelenin 40 yıllık tarihinde
böyle bir cephanelik ele geçirilmemişti
Hani bir orduya yetecek kadar silah ve
mühimmattan bahsediyoruz nasıl bir yer
derseniz içinde voleybol maçlarını
yapabileceği daha büyüklüğünde 3-4 katlı
apartman yüksekliğinde Hani tepeden
helikopterle geçseniz aşağıya baksanız
hiç kimseyi göremezsiniz Çünkü
teröristler yıllarca hiltilerle iş
makineleriyle bu alanları oluşturmuşlar
içinde tuvaletinden ameliyathanesine
kadar dev yaşamsal alanlardan
bahsediyorum
Biz bir yandan çekimlerimizi yapıyoruz
ama bulunduğumuz bölgenin hemen
ilerisinde de bir mağara mağaranın
içerisinde kıstırılmış 12 terörist var
hani 12 rakamı Size az gibi gelebilir
ama bu tür bölgelerde üçlü dörtlü
gruplar halinde dolaştığını düşünürsek
teröristlerin azımsanmayacak bir
rakamdan bahsediyorum işte ya sıcak
temasla bir çatışmaya girilecek ya da
teslim olacaklar Bu esnada gözüm Songül
yarbaya takılıyor Çünkü Sarp dağların
eteklerinde dimdik yürüyor sırtında 8-10
kilo ağırlığında sırt çantası elinde
silahı ve sürekli gururla onu izliyorum
mehmetçiklerin ablası olmuş Kimin ne
derdi olsa gidip Songül yarbay'a
anlatıyor
çekimlerimizi tamamladık çayımızı içtik
ve akşam yemeğine bir yer sofrasında
yedik hayatımın en kıymetli sofrasıdır o
sonrasında tümen Komutanlığına gittik
artık Ertesi sabah İstanbul'a döneceğiz
tabi içim kıpır kıpır Çünkü çok önemli
bir operasyonu görüntülemişiz bir an
önce haberleştirmek istiyorum sabah 6
suları bir baktım Songül Yarbay jilet
gibi üniformasıyla karşında ya dedim
Niye kalktınız bizi geçirmek için olur
mu dedi siz buralara kadar geldiniz Biz
sizi uğurlamayalım mı dedi Bulgar ısıtlı
bir helikopter hayatında birçok askeri
operasyonlarda
skorseye bindim ama Huger tipini ilk kez
görüyorum baktım Tam helikopterin başına
geldi Songül Erbay kulağıma eğildi dedi
ki sizin herkes fotoğraf çekildi ama bir
tek pilotlarımız çekilmedi sizin şimdi
Master yoksa olur mu dedim Tabii ki
beraber pilotlarla fotoğraflarımızı
çektirdik ardından o helikopter bizi
şırnağa bıraktı sonrasında İstanbul'a
geldik hani hatırlıyor musunuz Aydoğan
Aydın Paşa Bana telefonda ne demişti
duygu ve gururla istedik yaptığınız
haberi diye İşte ben de o tarifsiz
gururla hazırladım o haberi
aradan bir hafta geçti
Şırnak şenoba'da bir helikopterin
düştüğü ve içerisinde tümen komutanının
olduğu bilgisi yer alıyordu
acaba mı dedim olabilir mi böyle bir şey
önce Aydoğan Aydın Paşa'yı aradım
telefonu çalmıyordu düşmedi sonra Songül
yarbay'ı Aradım telefonu kapalıydı ve
Kara haber tez vakitte ulaştı içinde 13
komutanı Taşıyan o bir hafta önce beni
Taşıyan Kuğu helikopter düşmüş ve 13
komutan şey düşmüştü oturduğum yere
çöktüm hıçkıra hıçkıra ağladım günlerce
Gecelerce çünkü
tanıyıp bilip kahramanlıklarını
Dinlediğiniz bu insanların ölüm
haberleri kolay kolay sindirilmiyor ve
bir gecenin karanlığında tabutlar soğuk
Gencecik bedenler hiç giderken gerçekten
can dayanmıyor Hani hatırlıyor musunuz o
helikopterin başında birlikte fotoğraf
çektirdiğimiz Abdülmuttalip
Abdülmuttalip dünyaya gelecek olan
çocuğun hiçbir zaman göremedim
sonrasında beni arayarak eşimden bir
izniniz diyen eşi bugün 6 yaşında olan
Gökçe'ye tek başına büyütmek zorunda
kaldım hayatın üniformasını adayan
Songül yer var bu dünyadan göçüp
giderken de tüm mal varlığını O ablalık
yaptığı mehmetçiklere ve aklına
bağışlamıştı
Aydoğan Aydın Paşa bu ülkenin
yetiştirdiği Ender komutanlar
ama nice Kahramanlar var aranızda adımı
bilmediğimiz ve niceleri olacak benim
yaptığım
hayranlıkla izlediğiniz bu hayatta
Aslında Sizlerin de tanımasını sağlamak
ve en çok Analar ağlar Doğrudur ben bunu
en fazla da Malatya'daki köy evinde Bir
Bayram Sabahı Songül Yarbay'ın annesinin
elini öpmeye gittiğimde
iliklerime kadar hissettim 5 evladının
en küçüğüydü Songül'ü
ve Keşke o Gitmeseydi o ölmeseydi de ben
öleydim diyordu acısı bir tek uykuda
geçiyor diyordu
telefonumda yarım kalan bir diğer mesaj
Mardin'in Özel Harekat Şube Müdürü Şehit
Tufan Kansu var ne zaman bölgeye gitsem
Aman Nazlı dikkat etsin Çelik yeleğinle
Tahsin üzerine Çelik Kaskını geçirsin
Aman temkinli olsun derdi Kendisi de son
derece temkinliğidir ayak basmadığı
hiçbir yere tek bir memurunu bile
sokmazdı
kendisine verilen gazilik unvanını
benden daha kötü olan durumda olanlar
var diyerek kabul etmedi
görev süresi dolmuştu Mardin'de görevli
gönüllü olarak kalıyordu Ve o bana
kendine dikkat et Diyen arkadaşım
kardeşim Tufan'ın bir gün bir teröriste
yer göstermede kasını isabet eden hain
bir kurşunla Şehit düşeceğini hiçbir
zaman bilemedim
eşini tanıdığım kızları Nil İdil'i
tanıdığım sevdiğim sofrasında oturduğum
ekmeğini paylaştığım Tufan'ın bir gün
Bir kurşunla Şehit düşeceğini
aramızdan ayrılacağını hiçbir zaman
bilemedim
Suriye'de sınır ötesi operasyonlar
yapılıyor Biz de ekip arkadaşlarımla
beraber Kilis karkamış'tan içeriye giriş
yaptık Ben ne zaman bölgeye gitsem
arabayı kendim kullanınca rahat
hissediyorum artık Suriye
topraklarındayız cerablus'tayız
gideceğimiz yeri bulamıyoruz baktım
yaşlı bir amca hemen camı indirdim amca
beni gördü Şaşkın Çünkü filmlerde
göreceği o manzarayla o anda orada
karşılaşmıştı bu coğrafya hayaleti
olmayan birisi Üstelik
direksiyonun Başında tabi Bir sorduk
gideceğimiz yere anlaşamıyoruz o Arapça
konuşuyor Biz Türkçe işaret diliyle
anlattı ve ardından orada bölge
liderinin karargahına vardı terör
müezzilerinde çekimlerimizi yaptık akşam
vakti oldu Artık birkaç saat
dinleneceğiz tek göz bir oda verdiler
bize bir kanepeye kanepenin sağında ve
solunda iki kalleşmek Bu arada bölgede
hiç elektrik yok ortada bir soba sobayla
ısınıyoruz
Artık birkaç saat sonra yani ertesi gün
yola çıkacağız bu silahlar kalleşmek
oflar ne için dedik geldi dedik ki eğer
gece dedi bir baskın olursa kendinizi
koruyacaksınız Murat da şöyle bir
Birbirimize baktık Eyvah dedik inşallah
böyle bir şeye gerek kalmaz sabah 5
suları artık kanepenin kenarında
oturuyorum bir yandan İçim geçmiş
aradan bir iki saat geçti geçmedi nasıl
bir yumruklama kapının üzerinde yerimden
fırladım tam artık silaha doğru bir
hamle yapacağım çünkü herhalde basıldık
dedim meğersem gün ağarmış yola çıkma
vaktiymiş bölge lideri daha güvenli olur
diye aracını tahsis etti Bize hani araç
dediysem ve daha güvenli olur dediysem
üzeri mermi delikleriyle dolu Şükran
şehadet dediler ve yolladılar bizi
şu ana kadar hiçbir Türk gazetecinin o
dönemde de gitmediği bir bölge ve riskli
bir bölgeye giriyoruz Tabi ki bölgede
Kaos var ve tersine göç var Biz gittikçe
insanlar bize doğru geliyor
motosikletlerin üzerinde Kadınlar
çocuklar bölgeyi Terk etmeye
çalışıyorlar uzun kontrol noktaları ve
aramalar Allah'tan yanımızda mihalar var
yoksa derdimizi anlatamayacağız vardık
bir kilometre ötemizde keskin nişancılar
bir yandan da şöyle bir bakıyorum
düşünüyorum inşallah diyorum
üzerinizdeki Çelik yeleklerde basın
yazısını görürler de bir şey olmaz Neyse
kazasız belasız çekimlerimizi tamamladık
ve Tekrar Türkiye'ye döndük sonrasında
sınır ötesi operasyonları kapsayan bir
dizi belgesel yapmaya karar verdik
Milli Savunma Bakanlığı'nın katkılarıyla
Zeytin dalından
Fırat kalkanına barışmalarından Bahar
kalkanına bütün bu operasyonlarda
verilen onca mücadele Şehit kendi
çocukları ileride anlayabilsin
torunlarını anlatabilsin diye
bu belgeselleri yapmayı bir görev olarak
bizi kendimize Zira yaptığımız iş suya
yazı yazmak gibi işte Tam da o esnada
tanıştım Gazi Üsteğmen Özgür Ocaklı
zeytin dalı Harekatı'nda Görev yapmış 5
saat süren bir çatışma düşünün O
çatışmanın ortasında mühimatı bitiyor
Tabii belirli bir süre sonra yüzü
baruttan dolayı artık simsiyah olmayacak
olmuş tanımayacak halde Siri arkadaşı
son anda mühimatı getiriyor ve gerisini
şöyle anlatıyor Kendisi ardından korkunç
bir patlama oldu gözümü açtığımda
bacağım yoktu parmaklarım yerdeydi önce
yerden 4 parmağımı aldım önümdeki
Ceketimin cebine üniformanın cebine
koydum baktım kan kaybediyorum bacağıma
turnike yaptım birinci turnike ardından
ikinci turnikeyi yaptım Baktım kan
kaybın devam ediyor bilincim kapanmak
üzere kelime-i şehadet getirdim
ve gözlerimi tekrar açtığımda Aradan 2
hafta geçmiş ve ben bir hastane odasında
Ya diyorum Nasıl bir Metanet nasıl bir
kendini umursamamazlık Hani olamaz
diyorum Tabi bizde belgesel hazırlıyoruz
Bu duygu bir şekilde izleyene geçirmemiz
lazım tekrar anlatabilir misiniz diyorum
hani bir kere daha bir kere daha sonra
3-4 kere anlattı röportaj bitti yanıma
geldi Özgür Hoca ve çok özür dilerim
dedi ne için dedim
Hakkınızı helal edin bizim için ölmek
kolay ama bu tür işler zor dedi
defalarca size anlattırmak zorunda
kaldınız ve beni dinlemek zorunda kaldın
istedim
olur mu dedim Böyle şey olur mu bunları
niye anlatıyorum size Çünkü bu
toprakların var olmasına sebep
kahramanları tanıma Yılmak bilmeyen O
ruh hallerini anlayabilmek son derece
önemli Zira Vatan toprakları anne devlet
ise baba olarak mutlu ve incimizde ve
düşünün bunlardan mahrum kalsa
sahipsiziz Biz kimsesiz
Bu meslek çok şey öğretti bana İyiler
kadar kötüler de var Ve hep olacak
hep İş hayatınızda özel hayatınızda hep
karşılaşacaksınız bazen bilmek görmek
ama buna rağmen dimdik adımlarla
yolunuza Devam etmeniz gerekiyor çünkü
hayatta kötüye çabalayan insanların
değiştiremeyeceği tek şey sizin
duruşunuz olacak o duruşka sizin sizi
yapan
Zira üstü kişinin kimliğidir
son dönemlerde En çok da vicdanımızı
kaybettiğimizi düşünüyorum yaptığımız
haberlerde
izlediğim ve hazırladığımız kadarıyla
gördüğümüz sanıklık ettiğimiz kadar bir
nevi ahlaki erozyon yaşadığımızı
düşünüyorum ve keşke diyorum Keşke
herkes kendi vicdanı kadar yaşasa
Halbuki görüyorsa
duyuyorsak
sorumluyuz hakikate sağırlaşamayız
depremin 3 günüydü Hatay'a gittim daha
önce 4 kere gittim
insanına kültürüne yemeğine şehrine her
şeyine aşık oldum O Hatay'dan Geriye
hiçbir şey kalmamıştı bir toz bulutu
Karanlığa bürünmüş bir şehirden
bahsediyorum adeta hayalet bir şeyi
nasıl bir his vardı eşinizle derseniz o
kocaman bir Çaresizlik hissettim
Aslında o depremde Tonlarca
ağırlığındaki o betonların altında
hepimiz kaldık malzemeden çalan
müteahhiti de gördük kirişi kolonu
kesene de buna göz yumanında
enkazın altında Vasiyet gibi çektiği O
son videoda
komşunun da 2000 lira borcum vardı Ben
ölürsem onun o paraya ihtiyacı var
Lütfen sakın unutmayın o parayı da ona
verin diye Ne de gördük
elinde kalan son iki gofretin bir
tanesini paylaşan çocuğu da Hatay
kırıkhan'ın köyündeyiz bir abla yaklaştı
yanıma dedi ki Hali vakti yerinde
insanlardık Biz burada ama şu anda
ayağımda terlikle kaldım yanlış
anlamayın dilenci değilim ikinciyi
istemiyorum ama bir tane 36 numara
ayakkabı istiyorum sizden dedim sevginin
dayanışmanın gücünü de gördük ve Bence
en öğretici günler hepimize sorgulattı
hayatı imtihanlarla dolu bu hayat hassas
insanlar için çok daha Zorlu geçiyor
Bunun farkındayım Salt iyi Salt kötü yok
hayatta ve İyiler kadar da kötüler de
var Her zaman olacak Ama küçük olayların
küçük insanların tökezlemelerin asla
sizi pes ettirmesine İzin vermeyin Çünkü
her Birinizin hikayesi Biricik her biri
kendine özgü ve en güzel hikayeler
yılmaya bir amaca inanan ve işini aşkla
yapan insanlara ait
sahil kaç yılınız kaldı kaç günümüz
ertelemeyin hayallerinizi giden gitti
ama geride kalanı anlamlı kılmak sizin
elinizde dokunalım birbirimize
paylaşalım Zira nazik değiliz son
dönemde birbirimize o yüzden sevginin
gücüne inanalım ve giderken hoş bir
sadığa bırakalım hoşça kalın
[Alkış]